this is considered one of the best drafts in many
years Conor badar we heard about him for so long
and there's a lot of pressure on him and with the
first overall selection in the 2023 NHL draft the
Chicago Blackhawks are very proud to select Conor
Bard Columbus Blue Jack gets a proud select from
University of Michigan Adam fantilli he's one
of the best prospects this team's ever had they
should be really excited about Adam fantilli for
obvious reasons coming around the he Stars this
First National Hockey League goal cross I pass
scores the first in the National Hockey League
Ben Kelly wow great shot here by Adam Fant Tilly
welcome to the National Hockey League con Berard
upstairs his third of the Season upstairs what
a shot what a release EV fatelli scores what
a shot what a goal and he gets that Puck and
one motion he snaps it what a moment here pass
across bard scor and he scores Adam fantelli
yes sir the kid has done it [Music] again